[Music]
Lucey time to wrap it up just a few more
minutes
[Music]
as on my house from space not literally
that my life
[Music]
yep there it is
excuse me major Colvin has a theory that
he can tell who's walked in space just
by looking at it is more than theory you
keep your eye on this one
so I'll show you how it's done I'm so
proud of you
well being on the moon and back you know
Michael Collins of course Apollo 11
nefeli the command module for neon buzz
you know that after he dropped them he
circled the moon for hours inside the
module he wrote I am now truly alone and
absolutely alone from any known life I
am it I need to get back out there
gettin any younger so you're just gonna
have to work harder look at you straight
arrow yeah never the other thing wrong
in your life I've done plenty of things
wrong really
hit me
[Music]
dr. Plimpton said you skipped your last
recessions I'm giving everything to this
program to the mission kills me to say
it but our girls been pre inconsistently
she's tough cookie if the laptop
not everyone get in all right I'm
pulling you out of the running for a
riot no if I were a man you excuse me
I know what you tell him but you still
hope this is not a drill cadet grab his
stuff what are you doing with her I'm
officially beginning to worry
I'm dirt all systems go
what's it like up there only players
worry anything makes sense I hear that
[Music]
[Music]